hello you guys uh today we're going to
do a all Kila situation on uh
20 um 18 on the
cord
um as you can see on the
sticker we're going to use a generated
key uh by
outo um I've generated to this
FCC and we're just going to go to
emo we're going to place the km thingy
over
there and now we're just going to
press push to
start we're going to hit
yes we're going to go to control unit
we're going to go to keyless
Honda um ask us if the car can turn on
so obviously ly it's an all key
lost so we're just going to hit
no now we're going to press and hold the
push start
button just like a long press we're
going to hear
Beeps in that case i' like to leave it
and press it
again and we're going to wait for the
ignition to come on which it came on so
just remember if it doesn't come on just
leave it and press it again um it says
the ignition is turned on Please Release
so we going to hit
okay now remember um when we do this key
uh you always want to park uh your
vehicle as far as possible um you don't
want the car to be
um getting any signal from your car so
just park as far as you can so I'm just
going to go and move my car for a
second okay so now we just going to go
all key
lost uh we're going to hit okay we're
going to shut the ignition
off now we're going to place the key the
new key here and remember take all the
keys out make sure everything is
out um so the ignition is not going to
turn on so we're just going to hit no
we're going to press and hold the start
button like I like I mentioned before
we're going to leave it and hold it
again um if it doesn't come
on
so we're going to go OST
again we're just going to hit
okay place the key to be
learned in the
vehicle
okay the ignition switch is on I'm just
going to press
okay now we're going to tell him that we
want us register one key I'm going to
hit
okay
now we're going to shut the car
off we're going to shut the car to turn
the car on now remember every time that
they ask us to turn the car on you're
going to press
twice um it ask us if the immobilizer
light is off which is off we're just
going to press
yes now ask us to switch the ignition
off just going to switch it on again and
the job is
done we can turn the car
off and we can see that the remote is
working so this is how you do a job to a
2018 Honda Accord using this style key